today I'm excited because we are getting
a special early look at the newest
chapter in one of the longest-running
video game series of all time Final
Fantasy 15 and joining me today Elijah
Wood thanks for doing this I've been
forewarned that this game is a little
strange
so this game takes place on an
earth-like planet called yose and
basically in this planet there is a
magical crystal I always a crystal I
always yeah I'm sorry or a ring but
there's always or you must get the stone
either you will be a Prince Noctis
lucious calum your father what a name
again Prince Noctis lucious tailor I
don't ask me too many questions cuz
they'll actually tell you and then ya
know like you have to deliver a formal
address you know what this is this is
like middle-earth entourage walking
along and here comes their agent
remember good luck with your Japanese
nightclub wait fancy car broke down
right your car
pushing a car to Las Vegas play is this
really happening are we literally
pushing the par through a desert why is
this a game I don't know but that's what
you're supposed to do get out this is
where I struggle with our P G's because
it's a lot of just walking around
talking to folks kind of buy a potion
don't have any no need or any hard it
money I got no credit this is we're
trapped in a a Beckett play there is
nothing that's going to happen we're
waiting for things that can't happen I'd
be happy to pay y'all for your services
if you're up to the challenge
how about it sounds like a journey
nothing like running in the desert
wearing leather kind of like a boy band
it's the guys that are left from in sync
this is what they do now is driving a
desert and whether you think adjusting
will get back with us why did he call
any but he doesn't return our calls this
game should be called wait for your
death in real time further and further
away from my car and he was to rest up
before we set out good thing we have
that clean intent in our leather jackets
get the chips they got a bag of chips
those jackets have deep pockets well we
just decided to move forward because
that part of the game was killing us
okay and they're in Venice this is
Venice so at this point behind the game
the wedding has been called off why why
I've been called off
a lot of political reasons but you're
gonna walk over here and some ladies
you're gonna hit over here some ladies
and maybe have a mission they're
extending me
lady even the phrase wedding dress could
that be the dress we read about in the
papers don't think they read about a
dress yeah that's what guys like a
waiter on the road they're gonna check
out the dress let's go check out that
dress we've heard about in the papers
this is real let's think about the
ceremony I've never been this confused
by really saying something are we meant
to be confused no I mean if you play
through it all makes sense
we kind of turned me around it couldn't
possibly make sense well you know the
thing is a video game as written by
James Joyce it's just madness so hated
the guy fix our car he did but instead
of the car about one of the great things
about Final Fantasy that's in every game
are these things called chocobos oh did
the chicken I want to ride the chick so
why don't we get the car fixed and spend
so much time getting the car we could
just wait you can get on a chicken and
move around much more easily I don't
know an aggressive wasting of our time I
don't know no idea what our mission is
we're headed toward some mysterious
tremors in the area and we're gonna go
investigate okay why why is that our job
well we're gonna with me with the
seismologists okay oh there is just
waiting for us it's Kevin Spacey and
Angela Merkel oh there's gonna be some
kind of beast right the earthquakes
there's gonna be it's gonna be like oh
[ __ ]
Wow it's a really impressive Beast could
have started the game with this thing
you keep doing this trip I'm gonna be
facing the corner tell me when something
happens was that it that was the battle
but it did something happen that was
just to suss him out and then when you
actually battle him it takes three real
days what's the point of all this
yeah it's seriously it's the retake real
day it's a 72 real-time hours to be to
beat it
one time I beat on a worm for 72 hours I
was in college
we've been playing now longer than I've
played any game for clueless gamer we've
been playing for a really long is that
true this is the longest we've never
explained a game and we don't know I
don't know what we achieved I don't know
what we were trying to achieve I have no
sense of satisfaction just leave it on
this way yeah leave it on this cuz this
is a mess up this game the perfect way a
guy and a girl sitting on a bed in a
motel chatting you know nothing
happening this whole thing it's like an
epic blueballs waste of time so if
that's your thing final fantasy 15
and ps4 start it now the people be made
between outside and I didn't realize
they're watching this through that door
and they're still watching this what's
happening now is more thrilling than
anything
hello you've been working on this game
for seven months so you helped build
this right
babies will not be born because of you
will not be brought in from the fields
that said good job
[Applause]
good boy
you